un peuple résiste et montre que la
démocratie l'étape droit les droits de
l'homme doit être défendus au péril de
sa propre liberté et de sa propre vie ce
peuple c'est le peuple Hong Kong il nous
montre que oui les valeurs universelles
et la démocratie sont un idéal qui doit
être défendu partout dans le monde des
citoyens sont traqués enfermés réprimés
et aujourd'hui c'est jimmylet que nous
mettons en lumière mais en février
dernier ils étaient 50 à être jugés et
qui peut donner un chiffre exact de
toutes ces condamnations et répression
le Parlement européen a les devoirs de
les soutenir car à travers eux c'est
aussi nous que les autorités chinoises
attaquent ce que nous sommes ce que nous
portons il est temps de montrer à la
Chine que l'Europe ne restera jamais
silencieuse que l'Europe ne se laissera
jamais intimider que l'Europe doit
réellement créer les conditions de son
autonomie par une unité renforcée pour
ne pas être silencieuse pour ne pas être
intimidé alors où les autoritarismes
s'affirment monteront toujours au monde
et Hong Kong spécifiquement que l'Europe
est avec eux et nous les aborderons
jamais je vous remercie